on peut dire que le gouvernement a
bénéficié entre guillemets de duke aux
visées de l'actrice pendant un an et
demi qui a gelé la situation est une
personne n'avait que ça à faire
évidemment d'aller manifester
l'europe bien sûr mais ça l'a servi pour
finir là la révolte des gilet jaune qui
comme vous le dites n'est pas fini dans
le fond puisque le ça repart à la baisse
pour les pauvres le pouvoir d'achat moi
ce qui me fascine ce sont les prix de ce
qu'on appelle les dépenses pré engagées
chez les ch et les ménages les plus
pauvres c'était derrière l'argent qui au
début du mois est déjà engagée pour
rembourser vos crédits payer l'école de
vos enfants votre pass navigo votre
téléphone c'est ça ne fait qu'augmenter
mais c'est à dire que les ménages les
plus pauvres n'ont aujourd'hui plus que
300 et quelques euros par mois qu'ils
peuvent arbitrer c'est à dire se dire ah
tiens ce que je vais au cinéma est-ce
que je vais aller au restaurant et qui
sont de plus en plus ligoté par ça
pendant que en moyenne nous dit-on le
français s'enrichit la réalité c'est pas
du tout une moyenne c'est que vous avez
les plus pauvres qui se précarisent qui
se paupérise qui était la crainte d'un
des gilets jaunes de ne pas avoir
d'avenir de voir que l'avenir de leurs
enfants sera pire que leur et de l'autre
côté les ultra riches une progression
des dividendes de 62% entre 2017-2018 de
14 à 23 milliards et ses 23 milliards eh
bien ils sont partagés entre 0,1 pour
cent des foyers français elle est là la
politique la chronique c'est la
politique de louis de funès sauver les
riches et pourrait très riches et les
pauvres très pauvres c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer et je pense pas que
le gouvernement pourra maintenir son son
écran de fumée pendant très longtemps
dans du quoi qu'il en coûte qui a été
plutôt bien fait disons le puisqu'ils
ont distribué au bon moment ce qu'il
fallait aux entreprises qui étaient
fermés ou qui étaient en difficulté
pendant le pendant le virus mais vrai
avec quel argent encore une fois on ne
sait pas réellement et là je pense que
la facture commence à arriver donc ils
bénéficient d'un chômage assez bas pour
le moment oui et leur seule force
peut-être mais auquel il faut rajouter
ce qu'on appelle le halo du chômage
c'est on nous dit à 7,6 pour cent des
français qui sont au chômage mais il
faut rajouter 4 millions de français qui
sont sous-employés ou qui sont sortis de
ces statistiques n'ont pas de la fête
comme comme toujours